je déclare ma candidature à la mairie de
montréal pour les élections du 3 d'abord
c'était il ya quelques mois marcel le
côté qui se lancer en campagne
électorale en politique active lui qui a
été conseiller président et co fondateur
de secor une firme qui l'a créée en 1975
économe et ceux réputés
tout le monde a souligné depuis hier
après-midi les idées qui foisonnaient de
chez marcel côté on a réuni denis
coderre mélanie joly richard bergeron un
clin d'oeil vous avez bien sûr croiser
le fer avec lui on n'en est plus là et
monsieur coderre je vais commencer avec
vous si vous avez un conseil municipal
merci d'être là d'avoir jeu coderre il
était votre conseiller à 1 $ par année
ils continuaient à mener des idées des
idées pour montréal un marcel côte est
un incubateur d'idées c'est un grand
montréalais c'est un mot réaliste c'est
quelqu'un qui était un passionné y avait
peut-être pour faire de la politique
mais il ya mais la politique et il
savait qu il pouvait jouer un rôle et
puis pendant la campagne électorale
évidemment j'ai eu des déboires on s'est
rendu compte à un moment donné qui avait
quand même des atomes crochus
alors moi je me suis dit tout simplement
ça sans condescendance en autosuffisance
g1 m'annoncer parler après des résultats
jeudi marcel on va laisser retomber la
poussière là mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'on se parle il faut qu'on travaille
ensemble et puis
quelques semaines plus tard cette
science en mai 10 modes inédits je veux
donner j'ai des choses à dire je veux
contribuer jeudi garde tel bienvenus je
les ai mis tout de suite j'ai appelé ça
mais les trois mousquetaires gt4 donc
alain marcoux un roach étudiants pierre
desrochers et marcel et puis mettre en
branle déjà le plan qu'on avait pour la
réforme administrative et tout ça mais
c'était quelqu'un qui challenger
continuellement c'est quelqu'un qui
donnait l'heure juste sur notre
authenticité pour son expérience de vip
moi j'avais connus quand ils avaient
conseillé notamment robert bourassa où
brian mulroney on savait le ski qui
avait quand même c'est une éminence
grise en quelque part je voyais que
cette complicité qui se formait était
était vraiment une formule
gagnant-gagnant pour montréal et il
aimait beaucoup beaucoup de choses
marcel côté à monsieur le maire en
terminale il a mais les arias mais la
montagne
il aimait bien sûr l'innovation pour mon
rien il était pas sectaire il ne parlait
pas que d'administration il avait
beaucoup d'internautes s'étaient c'était
le don de soi c'était un grand passionné
je me rappelle on avait passé ensemble
la fameuse nuit blanche du festival des
lumières bleues à chaque fois y avait
quelque chose on ne fait mutek ensemble
alors pour toi comme moi je faisais pas
je faisais pas ça souvent on a découvert
des choses ensemble donc l'art numérique
c'est quelqu'un qui avait plein d'idées
mais c'est quelqu'un vente ou qu'ils
voulaient quand il voyait quelque chose
une formule gagnante d'un catalyseur
facilitateur c'est une courroie de
transmission intéressante on est à la
bibliothèque là et guy berthiaume mieux
radio majorat dommages à michel tremblay
et puis déjà il était aussi dans un
comité de financement pour bibliothèques
la grande bibliothèque ici donc c'est
quelqu'un qui va nous manquer je vais
parler à sa conjointe
dans si peu et puis on veut lui offrir
des funérailles
merci monsieur le marché coeur me dit
que vous deviez quitter vous avez un
conseil remercie infiniment je vais
aller à richard bergeron je reviendrai à
main à vous madame joly après je
bergeron vous avez appris à le connaître
en campagne électorale à montréal vous
avez découvert un homme complexe et fort
sympathique aussi j'avais quand même le
sentiment de l'avoir connue avant parce
que j'avais progressé beaucoup de ces
rapports dans le cadre de mes activités
professionnelles
alors je respectais énormément
l'intellectuel qui était marcel côté de
longue date puisqu'il a énormément
produits comme dirigeant de ces cas et
je vous dis pas que j'étais toujours
d'accord mais pour s'opposer une opinion
formulée dans un rapport de ces corps il
fallait travailler très fort alors
j'avais le sentiment de connaître des
gens les personnages l'intellectuel j'ai
découvert durant la campagne l'être
humain et il faut savoir que nous les
quatre candidats madame joly vous le
confirmera avec ce monsieur kader bien
dire c'est évident on ne se détestent
pas en politique on a conscience que
l'on en sait on se lance à titre
personnel et avec nos formations
politiques des défis vraiment titanesque
que c'est très difficile c'est un
passage
qui n'est pas facile et surtout comme
monsieur côté à 71 ans alors j'ai trouvé
très agréable de côtoyer monsieur côté
durant la campagne
et si que mes deux autres concurrents
bien entendu madame joly vous étiez
d'une autre génération j'étais arrivé en
politique
est ce que il a été d'une certaine façon
un peu un mentor ou quoi moi j'avais
l'occasion de la chance de connaître
marcel avant de me lancer en politique
marcel et moi on a été impliqué au musée
d'art contemporain ensemble on était
très impliqué justement dans la la
philanthropie des arts
et puis j'avais même eu l'occasion au
moment où j'écris un groupe de réflexion
pour de jeunes pour s'impliquer à
montréal de l'inviter à la maison et
s'étaient rendus il est arrivé en bixi à
la maison et on avait discuté on était
une vingtaine de jeunes avec lui et puis
ce terme montré extrêmement disponible
pour répondre aux questions et puis
vraiment nous dresser un portrait
économique de montréal marcel côté c'est
peut-être un grand homme et un homme qui
avait une vision macro dans le sens où
il ya peu d'êtres humains peu
d'individus qui ont la chance est d'être
vraiment la jonction de plusieurs mondes
c'est à dire le monde des affaires le
monde vraiment de l'entrepreneuriat le
monde de la politique tantôt dans les
coulisses tantôt deux factions pro actif
et aussi dans le monde des arts est donc
dans ce contexte local donner son
opinion sur l'opinion tenez compte de la
réalité de plusieurs milieux et c'est ce
qui était formidable de la part de
marcel c'est très bien résumé mélanie
joly effectivement il était à la
jonction de plusieurs choses et pour
montréal
il y avait une chose en commun entre
vous entre le mercader monsieur bergeron
et je vous remercie à tous les trois
c'est un clin d'oeil qu'on voulait
fermer ils avaient en commun cette
grande amour de montréal de la grande
région et des dossiers passionnants
merci bonne fin de soirée à vous trois
mais avaient aussi le droit au revoir et
merci